everything here you can get at your
local farmers market or have most
grocery stores if you have a Whole Foods
or like some kind of natural grocer you
know where you live everything that's
here you should be able to find there if
not you can find it easily online but as
you can see most of this stuff is pretty
simple it's just it's organic produce
it's nuts
it's grains it's a few oils it's a few
spices there's nothing really fancy here
it looks a little bit fancy because
we've created this beautiful
presentation for you and we have a
couple of exotic items here like the
purple cauliflower but don't be scared
off by that because basically everything
here is really standard stuff and quite
frankly with a few exceptions it's not
that expensive and so a big thing that
people are always saying is oh my god
you can diet plant-based diet how do you
afford it everything is so much more
expensive and you know I get asked this
all the time and the truth is some items
are expensive vegenaise have expensive
olive oil can get expensive but a lot of
these things are really basic stuff and
a lot of them you can buy in bulk for
example you know the flour brown rice
she is like beans she you see what she
sees in go along you can get them in
bulk that day you can think a lot of
times you can buy bulk potatoes I mean
these are not fancy things it's gonna
cost you more yeah it cost more than a
59 cent you know happy meal or
you know they're probably worth it and
it's not it doesn't have to break your
back it'll end up costing you less than
the Monroes because you'll be healthy
and you'll have tons of energy and
you'll never have to go to the doctor
medicine